Et donc là si vous regardez, on voit des petits machins qui sautent partout.
Ça, c’est des collemboles. Y en a partout entre la surface et quelques centimètres de profondeur.
On voit rien.
Mais silence ! On veut écouter !
On va encore froisser la première de la classe.
Mais elle a raison, c’est trop bien, c’est de la pédologie !
La pédo quoi ?
Non, non, non, laisse tomber. C’est juste Valentine avec ses jeux de mots chelou là.
Mais pas du tout, la pédologie c’est la science des sols !
Ouais. D’accord. Évidemment.
Depuis presque 30 ans, le sociologue des sciences Bruno Latour s’étonne que la pédologie ne soit pas reconnue comme une discipline majeure.
Et moi avec lui.
Eh ouais, la pédologie n’a pas la cote.
Même les géologues taquinent leurs confrères, parce qu’ils s’intéressent à des dépôts récents. C’est ridicule.
Autant étudier la poussière sur nos étagères !
Je ne suis pas convaincu que le nom rende service à la discipline susnommée.
Et c’est dommage que cette science soit le vilain petit canard de la géologie, alors qu’au fond, est-ce qu’on n’est pas tous… des Terriens ?
De toute façon, c’est déjà mieux que la socio ou pire, l’économie.
Non parce que n’en déplaise à Sheldon Cooper, la géologie, elle, c’est une science.
C’est un peu une vanne récurrente chez les scientifiques ;
on sous-entend que toutes les disciplines ne se valent pas.
Que les maths sont la reine des sciences, la physique leur valet et les sciences sociales leur bouffon.
Mais d’où ça vient ce truc-là ?
Qui a décidé un beau jour, en se levant le matin, qu’il allait classer les sciences ? Et est-ce que c’est bien legit tout ça ?
Oui, j’ose poser les questions qui fâchent et oui, je vais probablement finir dans une terrasse en béton.
Au XIXe siècle, le philosophe Auguste Comte propose la première classification rationnelle des sciences,
qu’il expose dans son «Cours de philosophie positive».
Comte est considéré comme le premier philosophe des sciences au sens moderne.
Et il a entrepris de ranger les sciences comme on classe des espèces. Littéralement.
Il s’est vraiment inspiré des biologistes, et notamment de Linné et son énorme chantier de la systématique du vivant.
Auguste (on est intimes) a donc fabriqué une « classification naturelle » des sciences, en essayant
de comprendre laquelle influençait laquelle et comment.
Et voici son chef-d'œuvre. On y retrouve dans l’ordre : les maths, l'astronomie, la physique, la chimie, la biologie et enfin la sociologie.
Plus tard, il ajoutera même la morale tout en haut.
Ces disciplines sont rangées de la plus générale (ou universelle) à la plus particulière,
de l’objet d’étude le plus simple (comme un triangle ou une baignoire qui fuit) au plus complexe (comme le succès improbable des Crocs).
Dans le schéma, chaque science dépend de la précédente et sert de fondement à la suivante.
Un bilboquet et un ver de terre sont tous les deux soumis aux lois des maths, de la physique et de la chimie, mais le lombric va en plus se conformer aux lois de la biologie.
Et vous saviez que les petits spaghettis que les vers de terre rejettent de leur cul, ça s’appelle des turricules ?
Nan ?
Vous allez me dire, ah mais oui je reconnais cette pyramide, c’est là-dessus que s’appuient nos bonnes blagues de scientifiques.
Avec les maths les plus mieux et la socio caca.
Mais tututut, pour Comte, c’était l’inverse !
Les maths ont juste le mérite d’être arrivées à maturité en premier.
Il dit qu’elles sont “positives”.
Mais ce n'est pas pour autant qu’elles seraient « la reine des sciences ».
Selon ses propres mots, “un berceau ne saurait être un trône”.
C’est qu’il cause bien le bougre !
Ce fameux trône était au contraire occupé par la sociologie.
La science la plus noble à ses yeux, parce qu’elle nous permet de nous comprendre nous-mêmes, toute société que nous sommes.
C’est, d’ailleurs, un des pères de la sociologie.
Il s’est levé un matin et il s’est dit j’ai rien à faire, il pleut,
allez je vais ranger les sciences, et puis après, je vais en créer une nouvelle pour la route. Ca m’occupera.
Mais s’il fait tout ça, c’est pas pour pimper son escalier parce qu’il avait vu ça sur Pinterest.
Comte n’est pas décorateur d’intérieur, il est utopiste.
Pour lui, les sciences ne sont pas une fin en soi, c’est un moyen de réorganiser la société.
D’où l’importance qu’il accorde à la sociologie et à la morale, parce qu’Auguste escompte un nouvel ordre social, politique et moral.
Et puis faut dire qu’il a vécu dans un climat de légère instabilité politique.
Il est né après la Révolution.
Il a connu un premier Empire avec un dictateur qui se prenait pour César 2.0, une Restauration (c’est important de se sustenter),
une révolution de juillet, re-une monarchie, une insurrection, une deuxième république, un coup d’Etat et un deuxième Empire.
Tu m’étonnes qu’il voulait redémarrer le système, il était plus instable que Windows Millenium.
Après avoir rangé les sciences et en avoir à moitié créé une nouvelle au passage, notre Gus recommençait un peu à s’ennuyer à  nouveau.
Alors, il a allumé la télé, il a larvé devant “Le Jour du Seigneur” et il s’est dit, mais voilà, je vais créer une religion !
C’était donc le deuxième volet de son plan machiavélique pour une nouvelle société.
C’est ainsi qu’il fonde la Religion de l’Humanité dans les années 1850.
Religion qui s’appuie notamment sur sa hiérarchie des sciences.
Sauf que ce qui est marrant, c’est qu’il était athée. C’est une religion laïque. Oui oui, ça existe.
En gros, c’est une espèce d’humanisme et de culte du progrès, mâtiné d’une morale basée sur l’altruisme
(mot qu’il a aussi inventé pour l’occasion, ça faisait longtemps qu'il n'avait pas créé un truc).
En résumé, « louez Descartes et soyez jonti ».
Un peu comme les zététiciens bienveillants en fait.
Il est allé jusqu’à créer un calendrier avec un thème par mois et un patron par jour,
de Moïse à Pythagore en passant par Cyrus, Léonidas (pas les chocolats),
Raphaël, Montgolfier, Conté (les crayons), Voltaire, Bouddha, Mozart, Confucius, Hume,
Henri IV, Louis XI, Buffon, Poussin, Michael Jackson ou Platon. Y a un intrus, je crois.
Y’a plein de trucs un peu obscurs dans sa sect—euh religion,
j’ai pas tout compris, mais je crois qu’au moment de ce tournage, on serait dans le mois qui célèbre le fétichisme.
Le succès de sa période rose a été plutôt mitigé.
Ses fans l’ont unfollow les uns après les autres, y compris ses plus éminents potos comme le philosophe et économiste britannique John Stuart Mill
ou Littré, le mec du dico là.
Ces loubards ont même écrit qu’il y avait un « bon Comte », le philosophe des débuts, et un « mauvais Comte », l’autoproclamé « Grand-Prêtre de l’Humanité ».
Et comme chacun sait, les bons Comte font les bons amis.
Du coup, le mauvais Comte avait plus trop d’amis.
Mais à l’époque, sa religion a quand-même pas mal essaimé dans le monde, notamment en Angleterre,
aux Etats-Unis, en Inde et en Amérique latine.
Et d’ailleurs, c’est à ce grand gaillard que le Brésil doit sa devise, ordem e progresso, l’ordre et le progrès,
deux piliers du positivisme.
Aujourd’hui, ce mouvement s’est presque éteint, même s’il subsiste un petit noyau de croyants au Brésil.
Ah elle nous fait voyager, cette hiérarchie des sciences !
On compte aujourd’hui 4 chapelles positivistes dans le monde,
3 au pays des favelas, dont une qui arbore ces ravissantes marches.
Et une dernière à Paris, en plein cœur du Marais.
C’est la chapelle de l’Humanité, qui a été construite par l’Eglise positiviste brésilienne (encore elle) d’après les plans du Grand-Prêtre.
C’est un genre de temple à la gloire des grandes figures de l’Histoire et des sciences.
La chapelle est rarement ouverte au public, mais parfois on peut la visiter pendant les journées du patrimoine.
Voilà, c’était le point Stéphane Bern.
Mais on s’écarte légèrement du sujet.
Revenons à notre hiérarchie des sciences.
Même en dehors de ce cercle restreint des adorateurs de l’humanité,
cette classification a fait forte impression sur les esprits les plus brillants de l’époque,
elle a été reprise par d’autres philosophes et sociologues des sciences et elle reste encore aujourd’hui le schéma le plus populaire.
Il suffit d’aller sur la page Wikipédia de l’entrée « science » pour voir par quoi elle est illustrée.
Mais tout ce que je vous ai présenté là, c’est un modèle. Je ne dis pas que c’est la réalité.
C’est ce qu’on va essayer de voir. Il faut tester.
Est-ce que l’observation colle à ce ravissant escalier des sciences tel un vieux chewing-gum de la honte sur la semelle d’une Crocs ?
La première question à se poser, c’est : quand est-ce qu’on mange ?
La deuxième, c’est : comment peut-on vérifier la validité de ce modèle ?
C’est ce qu’ont fait pas mal de chercheurs, avec des résultats mitigés.
Eh bien par exemple, on peut mesurer le degré de consensus qui transparaît dans chaque science.
La dernière étude en date remonte à 2013.
Les auteurs ont passé en revue près de 30.000 articles scientifiques balayant 12 disciplines.
Ils ont mesuré des paramètres censés refléter ce degré de consensus.
Par exemple, le nombre de co-auteurs, la longueur d’un article et le nombre de références.
En gros, plus on bosse sur un consensus, moins on aurait besoin de replacer le contexte et de justifier son approche donc
plus les papiers devraient être courts et y’aurait moins de références dedans.
C’est l’idée générale. Perso je suis moyen convaincue, mais admettons.
Mais là, vous vous dites oh là tout doux, pourquoi on s’intéresse au consensus, au juste ?
Ça sort d’où cette affaire ?
Eh bien, selon le modèle du père Auguste,
plus on étudie un truc simple et universel, comme un triangle ou un rond, et plus il y aura consensus sur la question.
Au contraire, plus l’objet d’étude est complexe et particulier, comme la réception de l’esthétique des sandales-chaussettes chez les touristes d’âge mûr
(pardon, les touristes “positifs”),
plus on aura de résultats différents donc moins il y aura de consensus.
Donc si ce modèle tient la route, on devrait avoir un gradient, avec un degré de consensus supérieur en maths-physique
et moins grand en sciences humaines et sociales avec un taux intermédiaire en biologie.
Eh bah je vous le donne en mille, c’est exactement ce que les chercheurs ont observé ici.
Quand on part de la physique jusqu’aux sciences humaines, il y a de moins en moins de coauteurs par étude,
les articles sont plus longs, ils sont plus écrits à la première personne, ils citent davantage de références et en particulier des livres…
et ils ne citent pas tous les mêmes sources, alors qu’en maths ou en physique les papiers ont plus tendance à s’appuyer sur un socle d’études communes.
Bref, il semblerait qu’il y ait le plus grand consensus en maths-physique, et le moins grand en sciences humaines et sociales.
Et effectivement, ces sciences-là ne se construisent pas vraiment autour d’un consensus,
c’est plutôt plein de petites écoles de pensée, parfois contradictoires.
Comme l’a dit Bourdieu, le Michael Jackson de la sociologie : « la sociologie est une discipline très dispersée au sens statistique du terme.
Ainsi s'explique qu'elle donne l'apparence d'une discipline divisée, plus proche de la philosophie que les autres sciences. »
Ce qui est pratique, c’est qu’on peut même ranger les sous-disciplines à l’intérieur de chaque science.
En bio par exemple, dans cette étude, c’est la biochimie et la biologie moléculaire qui ressortent plus « dures » que la zoologie, la bio végétale ou l’écologie.
Quoi qu’il en fût, tout ça va plutôt dans le sens d’une “hiérarchie” des sciences comme proposait Comte plutôt qu’une opposition stricte « sciences dures/sciences molles »,
comme on entend souvent et comme le soutiennent certains sociologues des sciences.
Ce serait plus un continuum.
Un peu comme un œuf qu’on fait cuire,
il ne passe pas directement du stade coque au stade mollet puis dur, mais c’est progressif.
Au passage, ces termes « sciences dures » / « sciences molles »
ont une forte connotation péjorative,
évitez de les employer si vous ne voulez pas finir au fond d’un étang lestés par un rocher.
Comme moi quand cette vidéo sortira.
Vaut mieux plutôt parler de sciences naturelles, de sciences formelles (pour les maths), et de sciences humaines et sociales.
Ok, collab Valentine steuplait.
Épisode 10.
Cpmmab !
Hop pop pop.
Alors déjà première question, c’est quelle discipline qui a fait cette étude ?
C’est des biologistes. Mais ils sont spécialistes des biais de publication dans les études.
Des biologistes. Carrément.
Donc là typiquement, pour moi, à mes yeux, c’est une logique de “science dure”, entre guillemets,
appliquée très froidement sur des processus qui impliquent surtout de l’humain.
Y a des conventions d’écriture en fonction des disciplines, y a aussi le style de la personne, etc.
Y a des revues qui exigent des tailles d’article qui ne doivent pas dépasser tant et d’autres au contraire,
ça fait pas sérieux si ton article est trop court, pour pleins de raisons juste éditoriales.
Voilà juste, ça fait abstraction de pleins de conventions humaines et de choses comme ça.
Y a des critères qu’on peut utiliser. Pourquoi pas.
Il faut beaucoup plus de finesse là-dedans.
La question que je pose surtout, c’est pourquoi on veut catégoriser comme ça et surtout hiérarchiser.
En fait, ces catégories-là, elles ont une raison d’être logistiques concrètement.
Avant, il y a longtemps, les savants, ils savaient tout de plein de domaines etc.
mais avec le temps, plus il y a de savoir, plus c’est compliqué de tout maîtriser et de tout apprendre. C’est impossible.
Ce n’est pas non plus possible de tout étudier au même endroit, donc pour des raisons logistiques, on a commencé à séparer
les lieux de savoir et à cloisonner un peu les disciplines.
Mais il y a certaines disciplines qui sont complètement à cheval et assez hybrides à la fin.
Même entre la distinction “sciences dures” et “humaines”,
par exemple la géographie ou l’archéologie, ce sont des disciplines qui ont des méthodes et des objets d’étude qui sont
extrêmement à cheval et des fois selon les labos,
elles sont rattachées à l’UFR de lettres ou l’UFR de sciences dures.
Si je peux me permettre d’ajouter quelque chose,
il me semble que dans cette discussion,
il y a un peu d'ambiguïté sur le type de classification qu’on recherche.
C'est-à-dire qu’on pourrait distinguer une classification qui pourrait reposer sur
les objets des sciences, puis une classification qui reposerait davantage sur les méthodes.
Et justement, quand tu parles de la distinction sciences formelles, sciences naturelles, sciences humaines et sociales,
c’est une classification qui repose sur les objets.
Quand tu admets ce genre de classification là,
tu peux admettre qu’il y a des choses plus fondamentales, ça ne veut pas forcément dire que les autres disciplines n’ont pas d’intérêt.
Parce qu’en fait, le niveau d’explication fondamentale n’est pas forcément approprié pour tous les objets.
Si tu veux expliquer une crise économique, partir des particules élémentaires,
ce n’est probablement pas une bonne idée.
Pour reprendre une métaphore, si tu as une maison,
les sciences dures, elles vont te permettre de comprendre comment tient ta maison etc.
Du coup, de pouvoir comprendre ces mécanismes et éventuellement de construire d’autres maisons. Ce qui fait dire à certains que c’est plus utile.
Par contre, les sciences humaines vont te permettre de comprendre cette lettre de mamie que tu as retrouvée au grenier et que tu essaies de décrypter,
et du coup, ça dépend totalement de ce qui t’intéresse.
Reconstruire une maison ou comprendre mieux mamie et comprendre mieux toi qui t’es et d’où tu viens.
Parce que mamie, c’est ton histoire perso etc.
Et tu vas mieux comprendre pourquoi en fait t’avais un malaise à chaque fois que tu as mangé des glaces avec mamie,
c’est parce qu’en fait, tu t’en rendue compte son amant le vendeur de glaces et ça tu l’as compris
en lisant cette lettre que c’était le vendeur de glaces et tu voyais bien qu’il y avait une tension qui te mettait mal à l’aise, est-ce que je suis partie trop loin ?
Nan. C’est parfait. Ça fait remonter beaucoup de choses en moi.
Moi il y a un truc sur lequel je voudrais revenir,
qui est cette hiérarchisation sur le côté de la reproductivité des expériences.
En fait, du coup, ce qui est plutôt de l’expérimentation, le fait est que la linguistique n’est pas une science expérimentale, on ne peut pas reproduire des expériences.
Pas parce que c’est une impossibilité théorique.
C’est une impossibilité qui est dû tout simplement à l’éthique.
On ne peut pas enlever les gens, les remettre en condition exacte comme serait l’état initial
et voir comme ça évolue et le refaire plein de fois pour confirmer que par exemple telle évolution phonétique a forcément lieu dans tel cas,
ou que telle évolution morphologique a eu lieu dans tel cas. On ne peut juste pas le faire.
Y a des trucs qui ont été tenté, comme empêcher les gens de parler pour voir ce que ça donne etc.
Globalement, aujourd’hui, ce sont des choses qu’on ne peut pas faire. On est obligé de se baser sur ce qui existe déjà.
Il me semble quand même que ce qu’il y a derrière, c’est l’idée que le niveau de preuve adéquat
pour les différentes disciplines est assez différent.
En gros, faut publier avec le meilleur niveau de preuve possible pour ta discipline.
Le meilleur niveau de preuve, il est très variable.
D’une discipline à une autre, ou même d’un champ d’une même discipline, c’est-à-dire que
pour étudier le français, le niveau de preuve auquel tu peux prétendre est plus élevé que l’indo-européen forcément.
Et y a aussi un manque de sensibilité de la part du public de ces différents niveaux de preuve.
Il faut comprendre que le niveau de preuve pour certains champs de la physique,
il est extraordinairement élevé que pour même un truc relativement banal de la biologie, c’est beaucoup plus bas,
et que pour l’indo-européen, c’est beaucoup plus bas aussi.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire que c’est moins bien. On fait au mieux quoi.
Tu viens un peu de nous philosplainer encore là.
Il ne peut pas s’empêcher hein ? Tu vas encore couper des patates ce soir hein.
Pour en revenir au cœur de l’article que je vous ai présenté,
il faut garder en tête que ce n’est jamais qu’une seule étude et les précédentes n’arrivaient pas forcément aux mêmes conclusions.
Bref, on ne sait pas si cette histoire de hiérarchie des sciences à la Comte est vraiment legit.
D’autres chercheurs penchent au contraire pour une opposition sciences dures/sciences molles, d’autres pour une absence totale de hiérarchie.
Mais hiérarchie ou pas, ce n'est pas pour autant que la physique vaudrait mieux que la sociologie ou la botanique.
Moi ce que j’en dis, c’est que toutes les sciences ont la même valeur.
Sauf la pédologie, évidemment.
Bref, Tout ça pour ça. On sait pas.
On est bien avancés !
Au moins maintenant, on a une meilleure idée d’où viennent ces blagues de cour de récré des scientifiques.
Et de toute façon, je ne sais pas si c’est vraiment utile de classer les sciences,
c’est un peu comme si on devait classer ses propres enfants par ordre de préférence ou pire,
ses crocs par couleur.
Ça voudrait dire qu’on en a plusieurs paires !
D’ailleurs, le positivisme de Comte a pas mal été critiqué,
et ses idées ont vite été dépassées.
Par exemple, on lui a reproché le caractère normatif de son classement.
Il range les sciences non pas selon ce qu’elles sont, mais selon ce qu’il voudrait qu’elles soient.
Et il le fait pour servir son agenda politique, donc avec une idéologie derrière,
et il va affirmer que le politique doit être au contraire subordonné aux sciences. Y’a comme un petit souci là.
On lui reproche aussi un certain scientisme, c’est-à-dire que la science est vue comme une base ou vient remplacer d’autres institutions
(par exemple l'Église par une église athée...).
Mais perso, je trouve l’intention première plutôt louable.
Comte voulait rendre justice à la diversité des sciences sans perdre de vue leur unité.
Il voulait lutter contre la fragmentation des connaissances.
Et ce qui les tiendrait ensemble, c’est leur démarche scientifique.
Pour citer le philosophe Edmond Goblot, « Une fois constituée, la science est une et cohérente, malgré la diversité des ouvriers qui l’ont construite. »
Je propose qu’on mette plutôt l’accent là-dessus. Qu’on fasse tous front ensemble face à la pensée dogmatique, plutôt que de se tirer dans les pattes.
Ensemble, louons Descartes et soyons jonti.
Aujourd’hui de toute façon, l’heure est au décloisonnement des disciplines. On gagne beaucoup à travailler tous ensemble,
d’ailleurs y’a des concepts qui ont ricoché d’une science à l’autre.
Les chercheurs en écologie ont piqué des tas de trucs aux économistes, par exemple.
Et c’est justement ça qui rend la science dynamique.
C’est comme ça que naissent des nouveaux domaines d’étude.
Mélangez la data science, la physique, la biologie, la psychologie et les SHS et vous obtenez la fouloscopie,
l’étude des foules !
Et pour s’attaquer au changement climatique, il faut bien impliquer la physique, la géologie, la biologie, la psychologie, l’économie ou les sciences sociales en outre.
Bref, nous sommes à l’aune de l’interdisciplinarité, la transdisciplinarité, la bidis… bref.
C’est l’instant LGBT de la disciplinarité et c’est tant mieux !
Soyons panscientifiques !
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo. Si vous l’avez aimée, n’hésitez pas à la liker, à la partager, sans rancune les pédologues.
N’hésitez pas aussi à nous rejoindre sur le Discord du Vortex pour discuter de tout ça.
Et retrouvez-moi en direct sur ma chaîne Twitch ScienceDeComptoir
dont le lien sera en description
pour débriefer cet épisode dès qu’il sort.
Donc, bon voilà, venez.
Salut les copains. J’peux me joindre à vous ?
Alors en fait, on a établi une hiérarchie de qui peut rentrer ou non dans la piscine et
là, ça ne va pas être possible.
Mais pourquoi ? C’est quoi vos critères, c’est complètement con.
En tout cas les crocs, c’est tout en bas de la liste quoi.
Nos champs de recherche ne sont pas encore ouverts à une telle interdisciplinarité, désolé.
C’est pas ce que vous croyez.
Un peu quand même.
C’est gênant là. C’est gênant.